my name is Leslie gross wertson and I am
an affiliate in the MacMillan Center in
the program for African studies and
Middle East studies I've also been
involved with the program for refugees
forced displacement and humanitarian
response
um and fellow for the center for race
and community and transnational
migration I remembered all of those
things so it is a real pleasure today to
introduce Dr Heba goed uh go ahead I'm
going to say it the Long Way
um who is an assistant professor of
Sociology at Boston University and
currently a member of The Institute for
advanced study at Princeton and her
research which is global and comparative
examines how low-income people Traverse
Social Services
immigration laws and their Associated
bureaucracies while grappling with
gender and racial equal inequalities and
she's published on these topics as well
as health and education as I as I
discovered
um
uh educational access for uh folks from
Cairo in race and ethnic studies
sociological Forum generate society and
American behavioral scientists
and um today she's going to talk about
her book Refuge which was published by
Princeton University press which is an
ethnography that explores the lives of
syrians seeking refuge in the U.S in
Canada and in Germany and the book one
thing that's really exciting about
having her back here is that the book
began in New Haven Connecticut right
here where heava was living and
volunteering among recently resettled
Syrian families so in the book she
examines weather and how these countries
recognize and invest in new arrivals
humanity and potential shaping their
economic realities and feelings of
belonging as countries receive refugees
through their social welfare systems
Refuge raises a mirror to how these
systems reproduce social inequality and
if we have time we might hear a little
bit about her next project which is
called the cost of borders which thinks
about borders and Border enforcement as
caught a series of costly and deadly
transactions so um I'm just going to lay
out a few ground rules for those in the
room and also those uh online first of
all um HEPA can't see you so if you are
online please use the chat or raise your
hand and I will do my best um to to
respond to your questions and to forward
those to her at the end of the time
um also if for some reason you're on
zoom and you're in the room right now
you need to mute both zoom and your
speaker on your computer and then
finally you'll just be asked whether you
consent to recording if you don't
consent to recording or don't want your
voice to be on the recording then just
use the chat function and I will repeat
your question for you so
thank you very much I'm looking very
much forward to hearing more about the
book and also having a really generative
thank you so much Leslie um and thank
you everybody in the room and online for
coming
um I am just going to do the awkward
thing of trying to share a portion of my
screens so bear with me there we go
we're good
um so thank you all so much
so much to you about my book uh Refuge
how the state shapes human potential
um that it was out as of April of this
year
foreign
okay so as you all know today the world
is facing one of the largest
displacement crises in modern history
and this is due to long-standing
realities of local violence produced by
Colonial legacies
um as well as newer facts of
environmental degradation and The
Disappearance of land and resources
82.4 million people more than one
percent of the world's population so one
in every 95 people are currently
forcibly displaced and among them are 25
million people who are displaced outside
of their country of origin and among
them 6.7 million are an estimated 6.7
million are Syrian refugees and you know
despite the fact that this Global crisis
is ongoing is worsening we're really
just beginning to understand its
ramifications
and so in this presentation I'm sharing
with you the findings of the comparative
ethnographic project that followed
syrians as they began new lives in the
United States Canada and Germany
countries that offered them a
resettlement and Asylum which the United
Nations identifies as durable solutions
to the problem of displacement and in
this project I focus on the experience
of displaced people who are skilled or
semi-skilled but not particularly highly
credentialed and who arrived to each of
these countries between 2015 and 2016.
and I'm going to argue that human
capital which we typically think of as a
crucial determinant of immigrant
outcomes is it self-structured through
State incorporation policy further I
show that the process of its production
is both gendered and racialized but
before I expand on this argument let me
first give you a background on how these
men and women arrive to these countries
in the first place how they became
refugees which is also an explanation of
their selection into the three cases
that I studied
the Syrian refugees in this study lived
in cities like home Syria's third
largest where this covered Market once
stood they became refugees due to a war
that began in 2011 as a result of the
government's uh violent response to
civil protests for social change the
Syrian manifestation of what came to be
known regionally as the Arab Spring
the war took with it the sights and
sounds of the neighborhoods where their
families had lived and the homes that
they had built and the lives of their
loved ones and at first people displaced
fled to areas nearby but eventually many
of them fled the country altogether
and most initially crossed into
countries of immediate Refuge countries
like Jordan Turkey and Lebanon which
continued to host about 83 percent of
all Syrian refugees and there they
registered with the United Nations
higher Council for refugees and the
thing about this is that you know you
have a country like Lebanon with six
million people
um and a million Syrian refugees arrive
there and so this of course creates
tension with local residents politicians
are using it to to foment uh you know
conflict and so and and also there are
not opportunities strong opportunities
for Education strong opportunities uh
for health care and so as a result a lot
of people felt that there wasn't a
future there and for those people there
were two possible solutions one is
resettlement and the other is Asylum
and resettlement is where a displaced
person is selected for travel to a third
country they're selected based on a
measure of vulnerability so things like
Financial burdens the number of
school-aged children whether or not
there's a chronic Health burden in the
household or violence and exploitation
in those countries of immediate refuge
and when offered resettlement to a
country they can say yes or no but they
cannot choose the destination itself
refugees are then vetted for travel
through an arduous process that can take
approximately two years the United
States and Canada led the world on
resettlement a program that takes in
hundreds of thousands of people each
year however given the sheer number of
refugees who are displaced globally
resettlement is a super rare solution so
only one percent of all displaced people
will ever be resettled
so for those not offered resettlement
the other solution to displacement is
Asylum and I'm sure many of you remember
watching in the summer of 2015 as almost
a million people with the help of
Smugglers made the treacherous journey
and blow up rafts across the
Mediterranean Sea and into Europe as one
Syrian woman put it to me rhetorically
do you know what it is to go into debt
to put your children in the arms of
death
Asylum is where a refugee Stakes his or
her Claim by going to a country that
could offer them legal status and
applying by some estimates Germany took
in about half a million Syrian siles
between 2015 and 2016. and a recent
statistic that I looked up says one
percent of all the German population
right now is Syria
so resettlement and Asylum offer those
seeking Refuge an opportunity to rebuild
their lives in well-equipped wealthy
countries with full legal status
but what do these institutional
Solutions mean for people who have
experienced such traumatic displacement
and who are embarking on New Beginnings
in strange countries
today we're going to look at
resettlement and Asylum not as ends but
as continuations to the process of
displacement and seeking Refuge
indeed by the time that the Syrian
refugees in this study had arrived to
the United States Canada or Germany
they'd experienced a number of
significant losses they lost their
country arriving to a new one where
there are then or norms and traditions
were entirely different
whose language was not their mother
tongue and where they would be ethnic
religious and racial minorities
stigmatized by association to terrorism
they had re resigned themselves to not
seeing their family for the foreseeable
future if ever again
but what's more they would experience
the dimming of their potential in
countries of resettlement and Asylum
their skills and abilities what we
typically identify as their human
capital did not have the same residence
as they did in Syria
the focus of this presentation is on why
that resonance is lost
foreign
so the term human capital Central to
studies and economics or public health
or you know all of the social sciences
refers to individual abilities and
qualities that make workers productive
sociologists have shown that human
capital is an important determinant of
immigrant socioeconomic Mobility
alongside uh the characteristics of a
receiving context particularly for the
first group of immigrants who arrives
in other words this literature shows
that human capital in context together
shape immigrant outcomes
human capital is typically measured
cross-sectionally as years of education
or occupational history
it's imaginative something that
immigrants bring with them an
independent variable that shapes other
outcomes however this leaves the
question if one had five years of Syrian
public school education or held an
occupation as an artisan in Syria how
does this actually matter for their
productivity and a destination economy
this question has been of interest to
economists who identify what they call
the imperfect transferability of human
capital for immigrants who are moving
across disparate contacts it's also been
of interest to others who identify
migration as a process as disruptive of
human capital
some have tried to explain this
discrepancy human capital theorists
simply say well you must not have the
necessary skills right signaling
theorists argue that that doesn't really
make sense because skills are not a
recognizable thing right it it depends
on whether or not they're seen or
whether or not people are understood to
have skills
um so it might be that you just don't
have the credentials that are legible to
employers regardless of the skills you
actually hold yet other theorists show
that the reading of skills is shaped by
racism right or that the skills of
minoritized groups are necessarily
always seen as inferior however these
explanations continue to treat the
Immigrant as a puzzle piece entering a
labor market puzzle but what if the
state that governs the entire process of
migration
so in this study I introduce a theory of
state-structured human capital
I argue looking at the early period and
through a comparative angle the human
capital can be created transformed or
destroyed through the incorporation
policies of receiving countries which
derive from National approaches to
social welfare I find that incorporation
systems can intervene in two ways first
they can recognize or ignore immigrant
history seeing people as unskilled who
may in fact have skills that could be
activated this has always mattered for
highly skilled immigrants like doctors
or lawyers but also in this study I will
talk about Amin who arrives in Germany
as a truck driver and he's worked his
whole life as a truck driver I showed
that this history of him working as a
truck driver only matters to the in the
German labor market as long as he's
recognized
um as being a truck driver in Germany
second states can invest in newcomer
Refugee skills so that they can
translate their histories in ways that
are productive in a new setting or
enable them to acquire skills that
matter in that setting for instance
seats can provide language learning
classes or teach refugees a new skill
that is needed in the receiving economy
but that they did not previously have it
can also provide financial assistance to
allow refugees to benefit from existing
skill building opportunities in the
context of reception
so for these reasons I argue that human
capital is not only a determinant of
immigrant outcomes but an outcome
structured by state incorporation
policies
I also show that the production of human
capital is gender as Scholars of gender
have shown institutions and services
themselves feature gendered expectations
of who is a worker these interact with
the syrian's own gender expectations
where men are often seen as primary
Breadwinners resulting in different as I
will show sometimes surprising outcomes
for women and men
I also show that the production of human
capital is racialized so countries equip
new arrivals in their pursuit of a good
and stable life through the very same
racist social welfare systems that have
longsheeped the Contours of national
belonging but what's more as Scholars of
race have shown discrimination and
racist violence diminishes opportunities
for engaging in the society in which one
finds themselves so minoritized people
may see your uh being in public space
and this was particularly true for women
who wore the hijab in this study
so now turning briefly to a theory on
immigrant reception foundational
literature in sociology holds that
immigrant welcome is contingent on
determinants including things like rape
social capital or legal status
the focus of this literature tends to be
on long-term integration or how
immigrants fit into a national whole
instead I join others who have shifted
the question focusing not on how
immigrants fit into a given context but
how context works in the lives of
immigrants I focus on the understudied
crucial initial years in which newcomer
histories collide with new systems to
coalesce into their first designations
of race of legal status and of human
capital
and this early period is crucial because
it shapes where immigrants start right
and how they then progress in these
destination contacts
I focus specifically on social welfare
policies which have long again shaped
The Contours of national belonging and
from Which social assistance for
immigrants derives finally I compare
refugees who because they receive social
assistance denied to other categories of
immigrants due to their legal
recognition as refugees our conservative
case to explore how incorporation
policies matter for new arrivals
but before we get to how refugees are
Incorporated through resettlement
policies uh the men and women in this
study have to first secure legal status
let's talk slightly about arrival
so in the United States and Canada
recognized refugees are admitted per
long-time resettlement systems and on
your screen is the approximate number of
Syrian refugees taken in by each country
between 2015 and 2017. Germany as you
see took in at least half a million
refugees and this was due to the
suspension the temporary suspension of
the Dublin regulation by Angela Merkel
that would have otherwise kept people at
the borders of the European Union
um and legally in the United States in
Canada refugees have permanent residency
within a year of their arrival
um but in Germany they receive a one to
three year renewable residency depending
on their level of protection right we
could talk about these later
um we're gonna keep it light for this
part of the presentation okay so what
are these countries incorporation
policies for refugees so each derives
again from the social welfare system of
the state so in the United States as you
all know we have a liberal market
economy and as one feature the United
States has limited social service system
because it treats poverty as an
individual failure as argued for
instance by Michael Katz in the
undeserving poor in her work Savelle Fox
shows up this approach to Poverty is
inextricably linked to the
disenfranchisement of black Americans in
the United States
refugees
um only regular cash assistance comes
from TANF which is temporary assistance
for needy families the national welfare
system offered to low-income people in
the country introduced in 96 the program
has lifetime limits and offers low
amounts of cash this design matches the
goal of both TANF and the 1980 Refugee
act which is for self-sufficiency that
the low-income refugees included should
not be relying on government assistance
it's important to note here that there
are other programs like match program or
like RCA but they're all sort of limited
in what the assistance that they offer
to refugees
Canada the second case is also a liberal
market economy but characterized by
what's been called inclusive liberalism
so what this means is that the social
service system in Canada is generous
providing Canadians who need it with
enough assistance to cover their basic
needs and this generosity shapes the
government's proactive approach to
Immigrant incorporation but that
proactive approach is also facilitated
by the fact that Canada has way more
restrictive policies for admission than
the United States does right so it's
whoever gets beyond the the you know the
welcome back welcome mat surrounded by
Nails as one writer put it
um gets this assistance but everybody
else is sort of kept out
and as Irene blow around shows in her
work immigrants and refugees are
received through what's called
state-sponsored multiculturalism which
means that Canada actively recruits and
seeks to integrate immigrants into the
fabric of their society by recognizing
them as ethnic minorities providing
instrumental and symbolic support to
them in that category
and so it's with this Express goal of
integration but refugees there are met
finally Germany is a corporate system
which means that the national economy is
organized by coordination between the
state uh the unions and employers to the
perceived benefit of all three
so the system means there's really high
levels of expenditure on social programs
and a highly centralized and Powerful
state which Meyer marks free for
instance described as producing the
German Nation and this nation was long
comprised of ethnic Germans as Germany
has a long history of excluding you know
violently non-germanic people from Full
integration
syrians entering the system benefit from
the generous financial assistance that
exists for the German State however it
comes with really meaningful conditions
so to enter the labor market which is a
condition of permanent residency you
need to First excel in German classes um
and then you need to earn a German
credential as you 85 of German Workers
so as a result I call the Asylum program
in the in Germany one of
credentialization
okay so how do refugees experience these
three systems before I get into the data
let me give you an explanation of my
methods and a little more on key
selection
so to compile the neat data chart that
you see on the chart before you involved
in ethnography conducted in three
countries over the span of three years
I'm fluent in Arabic and in 2015 I was
kicked out of my field site in Egypt uh
the long-term consequences of another
dictatorial backlash against the Arab
Spring
I was living in Connecticut when the
United States here right even when the
United States began to resettle refugees
to a local resettlement agency in 2015
and I volunteered As an interpreter
there where I met the 18 families in my
project who I got to know closely in the
coming years observing first-hand
meetings they had with the Department of
Social Services negotiations with off
the books employers and interactions
with the resettlement agency which is
also local
um sorry
so
um
and I recognize as I spoke to these to
these you know to this new arrivals how
important the United States Social
Services
though they were living in a liberal
city
um with a strong with strong Social
Services compared to elsewhere in the
United States in a very strong
resettlement agency as well they have
tremendous trepidation about their
assistance and also about finding jobs
they were living under the constant
threat of American poverty I wondered
how the experiences would differ if they
had arrived to another country and at
that point Justin Trudeau would run on a
platform of resettling 25 000 refugees
to Canada won the premiership and was
making good on his promise and flights
to Canada at the time were inexpensive
so I got to Toronto in February because
I was a graduate student with no money
so I got to Toronto in February and time
to see thousands of people crammed into
hotels and motels and government offices
trying to rent cars to go apartment
searching what was a brutally cold
Canadian winter
um and so there include five families
two of whom are related to families in
New Haven and all of whom were selected
on the basis of the same selection
process of those arriving to the United
States making them good comparative
cases Montana while Canada has a private
sponsorship program I include people
selected by a government sponsorship for
the sake of comparability though two of
the families did receive private
sponsorship support for six months as
part of a hybrid program which again I'm
happy to talk about q a
um and initially I visited Canada for a
month and I returned every six months
for two weeks and maintained contact
with these families longitudin vis-a-vis
social media
Etc I also did some focus groups that
participated in some focus groups that
were being done there just to
triangulate this data against bigger
populations
finally with the help of the NSF and the
Horowitz Foundation I included the case
of Germany due to the sheer number of
refugees were admitted there and because
it's a welfare state that's predicated
on very different integration approach
as I just described so in the summer of
2017 I included five families who were
related elsewhere in my study but
because this research would not be
longitudinal I returned in the summer of
2018 to conduct additional interviews a
sample of which were a sample of the
University of constance's national
survey on refugees which at that time
was just being launched I mean these
were mostly conducted in Bavaria so
regarding the study sample as you'll see
in the United States Canada and Germany
I compare refugees from similar
backgrounds um the men were truck
drivers chefs House Painters working
skilled or semi-skilled occupations but
without strong formal credentials now of
course refugees from any place are a
diverse group of people there are high
earning refugees there are low earning
refugees this I focus on this specific
group okay
um and the women for the most part as I
will show were also not employed in
Syria with a few notable exceptions
however uh in the German interviews I
also did interview some high-earning
refugees just for the sake of
comparability so I am happy to talk
about that there are some doctors and
some lawyers okay so now let's turn to
what these refugees reveal about the
incorporation policy in the United
States Canada and Germany
so
to organize findings in each case I
describe how refugees experience their
arrival
and the assistance that they receive
from the state I then explore how each
system structured the human capital of
these newly arrived refugees and how
that experience differed for women and
for men and I begin with the case of the
United States and how men and women
resettled here adjusted to the
self-sufficiency imperative of
resettlement policy here I highlight the
case of Roger imagine who just seven
years prior to their arrival were a
middle-class couple living in homes
Syria just around the corner from the
covered Market that I showed you earlier
in 2010 they finally achieved their
dream of building their own home leaving
the foundations in place to build
additional floors for each of their
three children the oldest of whom was a
preteen at the time their enjoyment of
this dream however was short-lived in
2011 they fled to Jordan where Majid who
had owned his own restaurant became an
undocumented worker at a shawarma stand
this couple along with their three
children arrived in JFK in October of
2015. an international organization for
migration fan drove them from JFK to New
Haven Connecticut
they were dropped off in a dimly lit uh
parking lot of an off-track betting
facility at the edge of town we all know
the sports Haven
um they piled into the car of the
resettlement agency caseworker and made
their way to a low-income neighborhood
of the post-industrial city
their apartment was on the second floor
of what used to be a single-family home
and they would soon realize it had a
mouse infestation and there the couple
would be visited by a caseworker who
would tell them what their assistance
would be
during this meeting they learned about
TANF for the first time the welfare
system they would receive 803 dollars
per month to benefit for a family of
five they would also receive comparable
amounts in food stamps through an
electronic benefit transfer apt that
could go towards food items at this
meeting they also learned that their
rent was a thousand dollars a month
here's a budget sheet from for another
family that's early in their
resettlement so because people don't
read English on the left is a clip art
of the expense and each column header is
the month which is family translated
into their Arabic names
yellow highlighter is the welcome money
um Federal funding which is 975 dollars
per Refugee and in green is what the
family is expected to pay as you can see
for the first three to six months the
resettlement agency and again iris is a
much more resource resettlement agency
than anywhere else in the United States
I'm using a mix of federal funding and
welcome money as well as donations to
the agency would support the family
however the family would immediately be
expected to pay half of the TANF benefit
towards rent while the agency would
cover the rest but when the assistance
was up right when the agency was no
longer supporting them between that
three and six months
um tan of cash alone right 803 versus a
thousand dollars for rent was
insufficient to cover it and so there
was no discussion in this family as to
who had to find a job as a household
Breadwinner this was smash's
responsibility
and this brings us to the issue of
state-structured human capital
tied to labor market entry measured
lacks and effective social network his
friends are refugees who are just as
poor as he was however through a contact
at the mosque he was referred to an
Egyptian pizza store owner he helped in
the kitchen
earned minimum wage at this job due to
the nature of the job however he had no
control over his shifts which is just
the nature of shift work in the United
States though he tried to attend English
classes his work schedule was
unpredictable he also did not have the
time or energy to study after his shift
low-income work in the United States is
characterized by precarity with
unpredictable work schedules and a lack
of a living wage as well as de-skilling
in Syria the men in a sample as I said
before were Carpenters electricians
contractors chefs and restaurant owners
when they met each other in the United
States they introduced themselves first
by their family name but then by their
man or their occupations
in the United States most did low-wage
jobs there were dishwashers janitors gas
station attendants where co-workers did
not speak English by Design right
because they didn't speak English and
where they did not have the energy or
time to attend English classes after
work
as one man put it I want to work but I'm
new here we just got here we don't
understand anything but you want to push
me to fishing to work so we work
whatever hi Allah most work in
restaurants doing whatever everyone is
working against their will no one is
happy in other countries they allow us
to study to get assistance they say
you're not allowed to work so you can
learn not here
meanwhile after the kids enrolled in
school roget and the other women began
to attend English classes in the morning
by staying out of the labor market the
women have the opportunity to build new
human capital
the English they were learning enabled
the women to do a series of tasks that
their husbands could not they could
communicate with service providers and
resettlement agency staff they could
advocate for their children in school
and they were building for the
citizenship exam that would take that
they would be eligible to take in five
years time
in addition uh most of the women within
a year after the resettlement took on
some kind of income earning task to
support their husbands the woman
utilizes skills that they have for
example reject crochet baby clothes and
flower pins and 26 year old Reda whose
husband had once said to me with
finality our wives don't work did work
she prepared sweets
that her husband sold to other
co-ethnics so in this way the women
reimagine their existing human capital
for New labor market returns
however as I learned when I began a
citizenship Clinic uh with the group
earlier this year even for the women the
gains were short-lived actually earlier
last year the games were short-lived
none of the activities because they were
not recognized by a pay stub were seen
by the Department of Social Services as
qualified work right because you have to
have qualified work which means you have
to show a pay stub
the women could not receive the limited
Federal Care Child Care Subsidy Federal
sorry Child Care subsidies that were
available to them because they did not
have the pay Seven because they were not
seen as working from the eyes of the
state Anna's family settled in babies
were born Sarah joked Donald Trump is
trying to keep syrians out of the
country but look at us we're making more
syrians here
with nowhere to leave their children the
women dropped out of English classes
also it's important to note that women
were also hindered in their pursuit of
language as a result of anti-muslim
racism on their screen is a hateful
message sent to the local mosque here in
2016 to Santa mosques all around the
country as hate crimes against Muslims
spiked including incidents against
people in this study they shied away
from being outdoors on their own and I
thought for instance stopped going to
English classes altogether after her
family was attacked and roget also
stopped going for a period of time after
this family was attacked
five years after their arrival none of
the men and few of the women had enough
English to qualify for the citizenship
exam a crucial barrier to inclusion and
protection against policies like the
travel ban that reduce their feelings of
security in the United States
so to sum up the self-sufficiency
imperative interacted with men and
women's division of labor to result in
men entering the labor market within
months of their arrival which reduced
their ability to rebuild their human
capital meanwhile women staying out of
the labor market because their husbands
entered and are stead were able to begin
to learn more English and reimagine
their skills in new ways but five years
after their arrival they too did not
have much by way of language Capital my
findings linked to National Data which
shows that though refugees enter the
labor market quickly in the United
States and are employed at higher rates
than non-immigrants they tend to have
lower incomes than the native born and
other immigrants and this Gap is
increasing for new cohorts importantly
um 20 years in over half of refugees
admitted to the United States continue
to have low English proficiency
so the experience of refugee
resettlement in the United States is an
integration into American poverty which
by Design is populated by people of
color and marked by stagnation
okay so now that I've given you the case
of the United States let's turn to the
case of Canada so a drive of 500 miles
north of New Haven takes us to Toronto
where denya a relative of one of the
families in New Haven lived with her
husband and four children zenya has a
laugh that can be heard ringing down the
hallway of her apartment building her
husband basem is a good deal older than
her and like mentioned he owned his own
restaurant and homes the couple has
three children including a son who
requires a hearing aid a hearing aid and
was placed in the school of the deaf for
Canada excuse me something that Denia
was really ecstatic about because he was
going to get proper education
when the Sam and denya arrived costi an
organization that was managing
resettlement on behalf of the Canadian
government housed them in a hotel
they would be allowed to choose their
own residence they chose to move to
Mississauga an area with a large Arab
Community where a market around the
corner sells the latest in Islamic
fashion and transplants the customer to
an Old Town School two other families in
my study chose to move to Kitchener and
Hamilton with a group of other families
starting a Syrian Community out of the
arrivals in Toronto people that they did
not previously know
the Canadian government gave families a
startup allowance of five thousand
dollars to cover first and last month's
rent the government also provided new
arrivals with standard issue new
furniture for their home for the
families resettled through private
sponsors the sponsors would find Family
a home purchase and furnish it for them
so at a similar level
this family received a cash assistance
of sixteen hundred dollars a month eight
hundred dollars per parent in addition
to the Canadian child benefit which is
approximately 450 per school age child
in a variable to available to everyone
who is low income and documented in
Canada
after the first year the families who
still need assistance would receive
Canadian welfare which is available for
low-income Canadians which was a few
hundred dollars less than the refugee
cash assistance but still supported the
needs of these families
the Canadian government as is clear on
their website anticipated this
transition from Refugee assistance to
welfare so they write
when income support from the government
or private sponsors ends after 12 months
in most cases it is a normal occurrence
for some refugees to transition to
provincial or territorial social
assistance support
so Damian bistam's Brent for a
three-bedroom apartment in this
high-rise was 1400 a month which they
would cover and exceed with this
assistance so the families did not need
to follow the timeline of families in
the United States they could wait to
enter the labor market in fact they were
incentivized to do so because they would
lose the refugee cash assistance if they
had income from other sources
this differentially structured their
human capital right differently
structured their human capital as it
allowed them to learn English and gain
skills unlike in the United States where
men had to enter the labor market early
and women were the ones who could learn
English in Canada the opportunity was
available to both partners
and so each morning the Sam and Danya
attended English classes a short walk
from their home after a year of lessons
their English remained halting but
enabled them to have telephone
conversations something that is really
hard to do in a foreign language and
something that neither the men or women
could accomplish in the United States at
that time and while there was variation
in the sample as to who attended
regularly everyone reported that English
classes as well as opportunities for
Education like courses through which
they could gain skills or earn diplomas
were free and readily available
the one caveat I will say is that child
care was a little bit spotty so while in
a lot of places Child Care was also
included in some cases like for a family
that was in uh in Kitchener it was
harder to access government-sponsored
Child Care however the system was uneven
in recognizing existing skills while a
blacksmith in the study could find work
immediately as a blacksmith for instance
a woman who was a nurse in Syria and who
had confronted the war as a nurse could
not be an equivalency particularly as
she lost her paperwork explained from
the war she was told she'd need at least
five years of schooling to become a
nurse in Canada
an electrician in the study was hired in
an apprenticeship based on his existing
credentials but he but uh he was told he
would need to pass an exam to become
fully licensed in the country
all three however and others in the
study benefited from publicly available
and free education the blacksmith took
courses on becoming a forklift operator
trying to find different things because
he had a bad back
um the uh the electrician was
considering earning a certificate in
engineering since he had to do an exam
anyway so he figured he'd get the next
stage of his education and the nurse to
classes in Community Counseling though
she wasn't sure that she could make a
full career out of it
the existence of these classes benefited
others too
um Denia said in her usual jovial
demeanor Denny that cooks and cleans is
over hollas she was going to enroll in a
class to learn to do hair and Yasin who
was on where the blacksmith's wife took
classes in food prep and began to work
at a restaurant
so it's important to note that in Canada
too hate crimes were high against
Muslims almost as high as they were in
the United States however the families
in my study in a sense that it felt
insulated from me and even though
ethnography is not a good measure of
incidents this feeling of security says
something because it was not the case in
the United States or in Germany one
explanation is that the syrians in
Canada unlike the US and Germany could
choose where they lived they had free
Mobility so a lot of them live by
co-ethnics which facilitated also their
economic opportunities
um they could also choose to live in a
Cosmopolitan place like Toronto which
has other immigrants
however I also think that what cannot be
discounted is Canada's active promotion
of a policy of multiculturalism by law
which as Irene Bloomerang describes
means that the state is focused on
investing in people through the
aforementioned language courses and
educational opportunities but also
through things like radio programming in
their language and support for co-ethnic
groups um and so this and these are
designed specifically by the state to
generate the sense of belonging
So In Sum through investment the
Canadian government supported refugees
expression of human capital and gaining
of new human capital through language
learning uh though their recognition is
inconsistent we don't see as a result as
strong about Divergence as we see in the
case of the United States by gender
Assyrian outcomes report it done in
Canada found that among
government-sponsored refugees who
arrived in Canada in 2015 43 had found
stable employment by 2018. so that's a
relatively low number as compared to the
United States however this has a clear
human capital trade-off because the same
study shows that 7 in 10 of these uh
people attended English classes
regularly over 80 percent reported
feeling that they could go shopping go
to their doctor's office and interact in
social situations entirely in English
and studies show that 15 years after
arrival Refugee income in Canada and
labor market with participation looks
pretty similar to that of other
immigrants and Canadians and their
English tends to be more fluent so in
some of the Canadian system by creating
opportunities for the expression of
existing human capital and the creation
of new human capital
um creates a stronger sense of sort of
stability and belonging um that we don't
see in their counterparts in the United
States
okay so finally what about the case of
Germany so arrival in the German case of
Asylum is much more dangerous than in
the case of resettlement
so Iman along with her husband Amin and
their three children arrived in Germany
in the summer of 2015. and me and who I
mentioned earlier in the talk was a Long
Haul truck driver in Damascus where he
was in prison due to tipping off the
resistance on a delivery of ammunition
after he was released from prison by the
intervention of his boss the family fled
the country they first fled to Turkey
and then a year later got on a raft to
Greece after an 18-day truck through
Europe including three days of
detainment in Hungary which a man
describes as the worst days in her life
including the war they arrived in
Germany 400 in debt to someone they'd
met on the way
they could not afford to travel further
to their intended Smita
after a welcoming arrival in Germany
that brought him into tears they spent
two days in a police camp and then a
month in a refugee camp and likes it at
which point they secured their
three-year temporary residency
this was a quick turnaround typically
the process takes closer to a year to
get the residency card if not longer
human and immune received assistance
from the German government through the
job center where all unemployment
assistance is distributed in Germany
their rent in Dusseldorf was covered by
the job center and they received a
monthly amount that covered their basic
expenditures and allowed the fit for
them to send 50 euros back home
um every once in a while
like in Canada refugees language
learning is the first issue of concern
for the German government
however unlike in Ontario Syrian
refugees are required to attend German
classes under penalty of reducing their
Assistance or canceling their assistance
as a result I mean any man enrolled in
classes in order to secure work in
Germany they would have to accomplish at
least a level B1 of German and so this
meant succeeding in four courses a
levels three a levels in the first of
your B level which would take a minimum
of a year but more realistically two
particularly for people who were
illiterate in Arabic or who were in this
you know semi-semi uh credential uh
group the classes also taught Basics
about German culture and laws which
people have written about and you know
they tend to take a racialized view of
the Immigrant who's arriving but we
could talk about that in the Q a
but then if Amin wanted to be a truck
driver in Germany he would need to do
training through an apprenticeship
system called an house build on for an
additional three years
his experience as a truck driver and the
fact that he had gotten arrested and
tortured in prison as a result of this
occupation was irrelevant it wasn't seen
by the German State as qualifying in
each work in order to find work in
Germany he would have to abide by the
same rules as Germans this made Syrian
refugees feel inadequate as all day a 31
year old former mechanic said the
Germans see themselves here if you want
to be with us you have to catch up with
us when you get here it's like you're a
newborn
another respondent was more explicit
calling the system racist and explaining
there's no recognition that I'm coming
from Syria with an 11th grade education
and that I want to continue to finish my
education why can't I just continue on
it's racist we left war and we came here
to be met by this race system
for some the lack of recognition of
their professional history as human
capital that matters for the German
labor market regarded on their giving up
on an attempt to secure equivalency so
in Bavaria BMW hired people for these
temp agencies and a lot of people
despite the fact that you're not really
earning the credential a lot of people
just went through these temp agencies
that actually were exploitative and took
a little bit off every uh Euro they
earned
but for everybody a main driver to enter
the German economy was a fear that the
German government um would not renew
their three-year residencies unless
syrians proved to be productive the
German government actually ended up
transitioning to one-year residencies
which left people feeling very very
um worried they trusted Angela Merkel um
but they worried about what would come
after her which we're you know beginning
to see now
so for women by contrast the
credentialization requirement cleared a
pathway to the labor market yada who had
married her husband a Palestinian
refugee in Syria when she was 15 years
old said that he would not have she
would not have continued education or
worked in Syria I dropped out of school
young she told me I wasn't a
particularly good student and I got
married young in Syria I would have
taken care of my house and our kids
in Germany however she wanted to become
a dental hygienist three years after her
arrival she was finishing up her B1 and
in the process of applying for an house
build on similarly modua who arrived
with her husband and one child and was
pregnant with a second knew that she
would attend uh she would also enter the
flea market she said of course here you
need two incons uh shrugging when I
asked her if she discussed it with her
husband she said it's an obvious thing
like for her it was expected that she
would enter
but here too it's important to highlight
the role of racism and shaping the
experiences of new arrivals the image on
your screen is of hateful messages one
woman received in her mailbox from a
neighbor
not only did new arrivals see the
policies of the German State as
exclusionary or as one respondent put it
a German system that works for Germans
but also they felt that they were
expected to relinquish parts of their
identities to better fit German like
culture or leading culture in Germany in
Germany where Turks are a substantial
immigrant minority estimated to be about
five percent of the German population
the syrians are racialized as Muslim in
relation to this group that is perceived
to not want to assimilate
particularly meaningful for the
expression of human capital women were
turned away from our jobs because they
were the hijab
for instance a 22 year old woman was
told by a government employee at the job
center that she could not work in a
daycare while wearing her hijab because
it would send a wrong message to the
children right so this racialization
this gendered bot and discrimination
exists alongside is integral to the
system
so in sum
in Germany the system of
credentialization ignored labor market
histories and length and Pathways to the
labor market there was a strong
Divergence by gender and that people
with lot with long labor market
histories often men were disadvantaged
by the non-recognition and people
without labor market histories who are
often women but also young people were
advantaged by investment in
credentialization however there are
important caveats given women's unique
experience of racism in this system
three years into their Asylum 72 percent
of syrians remained unemployed in
Germany according to you know uh some
data gathered in 2019 despite A
desperate need for them in the German
labor market where unemployment at the
time was hovering at just four percent
the ratio of skills and abilities
through non-recognition is detrimental
to assignese who have more to offer and
who experience Financial political and
emotional injury by not being able to
participate in the labor market it also
injures the German state that is looking
for their contribution so according to a
lot of people the reason the Germans
admitted you know half a million syrians
is because they wanted to use their
their labor
the case emphasizes that in addition to
the investment states make through
incorporation policies recognition is
key to expressing existing human capital
in short the presence of a German system
for Germans leaves refugees feeling
marginalized economically and otherwise
so now that I presented my data I
conclude by returning to my main
argument
the global ethnography centers the
experiences of men and women who come
from similar socioeconomic backgrounds
in their initial years in three
countries of permanent Refuge it
advances a theory of state-structured
human capital by showing that human
capital often conceptualizes the
determinant of refugee outcomes is a
product of national incorporation policy
and specifically whether countries are
willing to invest in and recognize
Refugee potential in Germany a
diminished ability to use human capital
as an outcome of a lack of recognition
of immigrant histories as human capital
in the United States the diminished
ability to use pre-existing skills in
the labor market is an outcome of a lack
of investment and newly arrived refugees
so that they can use their skills and
capacities productively in the United
States economy and in Canada a mixture
of imperfect direct investment in
recognition results in an ability to use
and create new human capital these
processes as I've described before are
gendered and racialized as are the
welfare systems that they derive from
and so what are the implications for
this project I'm going to leave you with
three
first in accounts of refugee crises and
in international laws refugees and
castles victims in receiving states that
offer these durable Solutions are often
cast as saviors
implicit to this is the racist idea that
life in the west is necessarily a
privilege and therefore countries are
accomplishing their humanitarian
commitment simply by admitting refugees
but admission into American poverty is
no one's salvation indeed wealthy
countries that receive refugees
including the United States Canada and
Germany are complicit in the colonial
legacies foreign military interventions
environmental degradation that create
the very conditions from which refugees
are fleeing and within their borders
they too are capable of violence the
violence of minoritizing of denying
living wages of a non-recognition of
people's Humanity
so this project captures how countries
equip new arrivals for their pursuit of
a good stable life through the very same
systems that have long shaped The
Contours of national belonging
second in following observing how the
human capital of those seeking Refuge is
structured reveals the ways in which it
matters well beyond the labor market
language acquisition is necessary for
everything for making friends to
securing citizenship in all three of
these countries
and the ability to express human
potential is emotionally important how
would any of us feel if all we have
accomplished and built professionally
suddenly became completely meaningless
to everybody around us
finally the study has implications well
beyond the case of refugees or even
immigrants through a design that follows
the simultaneous experience of people
seeking Refuge who are strangers to
these systems of social welfare we raise
a mirror to the systems themselves and
how they shape inequality more broadly
the national incorporation policies that
structure the human capital of refugees
are the same systems which low-income
people have traversed across these three
countries for decades right if not
centuries well before this cohort of
Syrian refugees arrived thank you
I'm going to move over here so I can
facilitate the um the in-person and the
online
um questions I'm sure there's a lot it
was a very rich talk very provocative I
think there's a lot that we could get
into from each of the three cases so
what I'll do is for people online invite
you to either raise your hand or put a
question in the chat and then folks in
the room if you raise your hand I'll um
I'll do my best to make sure that
everyone can ask a question when they
want to
I'm not going to unmute myself
so any questions to start with in the
room please
thank you for the talk it was so
motivating I think my first question is
and I don't know if this necessarily
makes sense for the different dimensions
of integration
um
comparison when you brought in other
factors because I think when we think
resettlement the typical or not typical
obviously the important markers are you
know does someone get it for does
someone have access to care what
but there's also these other dimensions
and one that's of interest to me is like
family reunification and so one thing
that I've noticed in a lot of this like
conversation especially among Syrian
refugees in different countries is that
oh well in the United States is able
you're able to bring your family after
you have citizenship and Canada is a
little bit more difficult and Europe
it's almost impossible so did that also
factor into your analysis yeah so my
final chapter so here I'm really
presenting on the three country
comparison but my there's two chapters
in my book that don't really that get
short shrifted in this kind of
presentation because you can't really do
the whole the whole thing in it and one
is the Final Chapter which is called
here and there which is about both
remittances and family reunification
what kinds of burdens and guilt do
people feel when they're here when
they've made it and their family is
there in sort of destitution and poverty
struggling
um and so how do they bring them over
and one of the arguments that I make is
that your ability to get employed to
make an income but also to learn
language is entirely related to your
ability to bring your family because if
you're if you're put in a situation
where you're disadvantaged and you're
not attending English classes and you're
not making enough money then the
likelihood of you being able to pay for
the citizenship which is which is
expensive right unless you remain on
government services but also be able to
sit and take the citizenship exam which
is an English Language exam they
actually test you on your English is
very low so actually in an intervention
that I did post book I started a
citizenship Clinic at Boston University
what I do is I bring people who are
learning uh Arabic students who are
learning in the Arabic Department with
refugees who are trying to study for the
citizenship exam I developed a
curriculum that teaches to the Civics
exam and then they have one-on-one
tutoring with the students and the
teachers and we actually had 11 people
past the citizenship exam as a result of
that um you know as a result of their
hard work of course but as also as a
result of that intervention because you
know it's an exam that you can pass if
you study to it but there aren't really
that that many resources to help people
across that burden so I think that these
are all related stories right and we
think about about family reunification
just on the basis of the laws but you
need the resources to even be able to
qualify under those laws for sure
um in there are you are absolutely right
there are different restrictions on
family reunification so there's the
immediate family which you can bring in
the United States prior to securing your
Refugee status
um in in Canada in some instances in
Germany they actually truncated that
that's why I moved from three-year
residencies to one-year residency so
that's a really interesting case to look
at in terms of family reunification
because under subsidiary protection
which is the one-year protection you
cannot reunify your family and that was
their attempt to stop and that actually
a lot of people self-deported
because they were fathers who got to
Germany and their intention was to unify
their family they just didn't want them
to go on the boat with them because they
were you know worried about their
family's safety and also because it's
very expensive so they waited until they
got to Germany and they tried to reunify
with their families and then when they
got this one year subsidiary protection
their families were in unsafe positions
and refugee camps and other places so
they just went back
um and it's a really sad sad scenario
yes thank you
thank you for this talk it was one
called so in the US and in Canada
but then in Germany it seemed that
racism and the experience of racism
really came through why do you think
there was that difference or was that
was it
[Music]
yeah I think I think that's a really uh
good question I think that in the United
States so I I will tell you another
example I mean I mean y'all just heard
me microaggressed here but in the German
case in the German case it happens in in
Europe I'm sorry
I told Leslie that I tend to fear so you
almost have to move me back
um but in in every time I give a talk in
Germany and this is a roundabout way to
answer your question but every time I
give a talk in Europe
um somebody asks me a Bonkers question
about you know that assumes that race
doesn't exist
every single time you know maybe there's
like very few exceptions
um I was actually uh one argument he
said well you can't just make anything
up syrians and Italians are the same
skin tone
right this was his argument right and so
when we think about it I think that in
the United States
um we address race and racism in ways we
have a different language not to say
that it's less racist I think you know I
don't think that we can talk about
magnitude I don't think it's a useful
conversation to have about what places
are more or less racist but I do think
that we have a conversation about it
here was in the German case it's all
talked about in terms of culture and
even educated academics even
sociologists we'll sit in front of me
and and be like race does not exist
right oh this is just cultural
differences what we have as Germans have
a right to want to have our culture in
our country right as though they didn't
do the Holocaust right and so like you
know what does it mean to what does
culture mean in that regard and I argue
that this is a story of race and racism
this is an ordinal categorization of
people right and so you know when we
think about these things we have to put
them in that context and I think in
Germany
um in one's case they were very visible
there were lots of people it was a
highly politicized case
um Germany has a massive history with uh
you know you know they have massive
Neo-Nazi uh elements and there's just
not that much pushback
and there's really American history not
American History X sorry um there's a
podcast called something X in the New
York Times does anybody know what I'm
talking about that was about Germany and
about race and racism in Germany and
about you know how people experience it
um and then Neo-Nazi movement and how
it's infiltrated also with the policing
Etc there
so we have two questions so we have two
questions online and then we'll move to
Aroma well we've got we've got a lot so
we'll I'm gonna try to put these
together for us um so Ahmed
um thank you for an interesting
presentation and wanted to to ask about
forms of resilience
um that participants Express that
expanded their agency so sort of the
resiliency I guess practices
um that demonstrated that this is a
story of agency and fighting back right
it's a story of systems that don't
enable people and it's a story of agency
and fighting back so when I talk about
structure when I'm talking about the
reason I'm focusing on the welfare
systems is to say that here are the
freight here is the framework in which
people have to operate but people
um the eitc the
um the Earned Income Tax Credit was a
huge uh resource that people use the
earningham tax credit for those who
don't know is a government subsidy for
low-income families
um and it's actually one of the more
effective if you ask me what my two
favorite government subsidies are or
what two favorite you know poverty
interventions are either earn income tax
credit and food stamps right I mean
honestly I mean they're all but like it
would be the earning of tax credit and
food stamps and it's because I have seen
people who use that money which comes in
April as like a little bit of a bulk
audience but you know for a low-income
families it would a lot of children
could be as much as five thousand
dollars and use that to invest in a car
or to use that to help them with the
down payment on a house or to use that
even to invest in a business you know
people have also sold um property in
Syria at a huge huge discount
um that they have you know once things
calm down a little bit we're able to use
that money
um people
um you know people have uh you know
communicated with each other made
Partnerships with each other sometimes
those fail because you're basically like
you know everybody's kind of in a
precarious place and so it's really hard
to start a business
um but these are all different ways that
people have pushed back I also think
that you know learning language in these
conditions is a huge form of resilience
and a huge form of agency so I see this
as an entirely a story of resistance and
if you're interested in that also the
afterword of the book is written by
people from each case so it's written by
a woman from the United States a woman
resettled in the United States a one
resettled in Canada and a man resettled
in Germany and they talk about it from
their own perspective sort of what they
did and how they managed and that was
important to me for two reasons was to
do something you know that was five
years after their arrival but also um to
include people's voices unfiltered by my
analysis um in the in the book
I have a point of pricing a question to
fall on the paraphrase because I think
there's to go back to the comment on
colonialism the the way that often even
social scientists frame immigration it
reminds me of the way that uh colonial
governments would talk about like the
Indian problem right as if the problem
is people as opposed to what we are
doing to people and so I love how your
books as well relation is not this
people but the systems that they're
getting into and then doesn't not just
with a very rightful moral lens but also
in an analytical list and my question is
about the German keys because in the U.S
you make very clear I think convincingly
so that the welfare system is a
racialized system you know there's the
work of civil fogs there's you know you
can look at the work of historian
Elizabeth Hinton uh then in the case of
Canada you have a more you know the
Multicultural approach in the case of
Germany I kept because you did mention
there the huge huge Turkish minority
that exists in Germany uh yeah how I
mean
intuitively I would think that there's
something about the way the systems have
been designed around not just around
Skilling and certification but around
this Turkish minority that could have
effects on how they are dressed serious
is this a thing or is it just me so the
German minority came through a guest
labor project and so what's really
interesting about the German case is
until the 1990s they described the
German official stance on immigration
was Germany is not a country of
immigration it's like in there like that
was their official policy of immigration
because Germany is not a country
it was only in 2000 that they allowed
anybody with non-germanic blood
kid you not non-germanic blood to get
Turkish citizens to get sorry German
citizenship so 100 this exclusionary
story is about Germans like hegemonics
or white supremacist notion of their
country and there's really interesting
stuff done um I'm blinking on her name
but there's an ethnographer who linked
the relate the the treatment of Turks of
the treatment of Jews in Germany and she
has like a very interesting I can send
you that it's cited in the book but I
can't remember her name right now um so
there's a really interesting sort of
story there
yes
um well no no not Elizabeth no because
she was at Yale not Liz
no it was somebody older somebody before
maybe it was Elizabeth wait Elizabeth
maybe I look I'll look it up I'll look
it up I don't want to say the wrong name
I'll look it up um but but somebody who
wrote a book about this and so you know
when we think about it when we think
about what a racialized system is right
we have to think about you know who does
the system exclude and in the German
case you're right it's not exactly the
cases in the United States where it's in
a system designed to exclude you know
like this you know notion of The Welfare
Queen right it's a very like racist
system through its like Inception right
language and the rhetoric around it in
the German case it's just a story of
refusing to include right of having this
closed system that only imagines the
German polity as white Germans even as
their quality actually becomes more and
more diverse right even as Turkish
people will become five percent of the
population syrians become one percent of
the population and the unwillingness or
inability to sort of shift the system
now there have been some attempts so
there's a recognition act
um that was done in 2012 and revamped in
2016. um but that's only for people with
formal credentials and what's really
interesting about that is the Germans
are really good about publishing their
data that is a that is a point in their
favor and um and they the data shows
that they are very unlikely to recognize
syrians even when they are doctors or
lawyers with the formal credential so
there's only a 32 recognition rate for
syrians who arrive in Germany versus if
you arrive from the European Union
there's like an 87 recognition rate for
your credential
there's a there's a question about
religion here
um so I'm gonna let me get back to it um
just wondering maybe if you can speak a
little bit about
um so this is from Samira uh about how
religion factors not only into sort of
the daily lives of of resettled people
or refugees but also maybe people who
help volunteer or participate in Refugee
resettlement
um and uh they also had a question like
related about
um
about the ways in which um refugees
might be invited into countries that
seem secular or there's a there's a
language of secularity but there's
expectations of certain acceptable and
unacceptable religions or practices yeah
I mean you know I I again I talk about
um I I I'm kind of um phobic to talk
about islamophobia the reason why I
don't talk about islamophobia is because
phobia is something that you feel that's
like a visceral reaction to something
um instead when we talk about
anti-muslim sentiments I prefer to talk
about it as a racism and the reason why
I prefer to talk about it as a racism is
because you can't understand it unless
you place it within the American racial
system right within the anti-black um
anti you know you know the killing of
indigenous people the way that the
system has been anti-immigrant right how
how our laws have transformed around the
fact that you know that the Imagine
beneficiary Essence about Fox's work
became you know low-income Mexicans and
black people right that's a very
different kind of story if you place it
within that framework and who is so
another better way to think about this
is like you know the reason why Arabs in
the United States are identified as
white on uh you know all of the
documents and the census Etc is because
you had to be white by law in order to
naturalize in the United States but
George Dao one of the primary cases that
um that proved this right stood in front
of a judge in you know the early 1900s
and said to the judge I'm white because
I am related to Jesus
right because this guy was Palestinians
he's like I'm white if you think Jesus
was white I'm 100 white because we come
from the same place and he won yeah
right so whiteness in the United States
has always been based around a Christian
framework and so when we think about
this when we think about who's included
and who's excluded and how race works
you have to think about anti-muslim
sentiment as a form of racism now in
terms of who helps yes mosques are
available
um churches you know I I'm old enough to
remember you know in 2014 2013 the vast
majority of the work of resettlements
done by Evangelical churches in the
south of the United States right so like
you know and it was this idea of
welcoming The Stranger In Jesus as a
refugee right so there is so religiosity
has always played a role for people
helping across religions whether they
want to evangelize but also whether they
just you know feel like it's their
obligation to welcome people
um but also for co-ethnics with other um
co-ethnics and then there was this move
you know that that you know under Trump
that we should only be accepting
Christian refugees so of course
religiosity plays a role in who feels
the need to support whom and whether and
who actually gets involved in the work
of resettlement for sure
we had a couple with one in the back
there
go ahead
there's so much
um in terms of uh
Canada uh
um is there a fundamental reason why U.S
and Germany are used in Germany systems
won't conclude the Canadian systems in
the future or it's just evolutionary
courses they will learn from it
I think so I I think they're fully
capable did I interrupt you I'm so sorry
okay I think they're I think so I've
been talking about this a lot recently
because when the Ukrainian displacement
happened uh some somehow people became
interested in displacement in general so
I got invited to give a lot of talks and
one of the reasons that one of the
things that I say is that you know when
ukrainians were admitted for instance
over the U.S Mexico border
um the people the Customs and Border
Patrol officers were told by the Biden
Administration to use their discretion
when it came to ukrainians what that
tells me is that discretion was always a
possibility in that case at that border
right and so do they have the capacity
to converge with Canada does Canada have
the capacity to do better absolutely I
think the question is a question of
political will do we actually have an
interest in this country of reforming
our systems not only for refugees but
also for other immigrants and also for
low-income people I think the answer
historically has been no
um I hope we see more about conversions
but I don't think even though and I
would argue I could make an argument an
economic argument I could say if you are
only interested in money and you still
want to admit people it's more cost
effective for you to invest in them in
the beginning in terms of the return
that you'll get long term I don't make
that argument because I don't think we
should just assign dollar values to
people but I do think I could make that
argument and so you know but the idea is
there's just not a willingness there is
not an imagination of the new arrivals
as beneficiary beneficial to us instead
it's an imagination of them as burdens
right security threats Muslims who are
who might do terrorism uh low-income
people who are going to be drains on the
system all of this rhetoric and so
instead of
um investing our our approaches to
mitigate threat and that's a completely
different imagination right than than a
case where we where we actually actively
invest in people
yeah
hi I'm Michael
um so my question
um I've got my hands on your book yet so
I apologize if it's in you know there
and I'll get to it um but my question is
about what here in the U.S I've heard as
like the non-profit industrial complex
and so trying to learn more about how
this idea of or how
the assistance part of your analysis how
that looks in Canada in Germany if we
think about the non-profits which you
know from my understanding you know are
connected to the state are still State
structured but are you know it yeah
they're fundamentally State entities in
the United States because resettlement
while technically a government system is
actually entirely done in the Eis
through ngos in Canada it's not that's
not entirely the case because your
government assistance does arrive
directly from the government in the
United States you're welcome money
arrives through the resettlement
agencies
um I am I am how do I I feel like it's
misplaced I I you know I the the the
stuff the criticism of ngos I think is
really well founded I made a decision in
the book to focus on government policies
because I think it's misplaced criticism
like could ngos do better in their
position could they do better to
Advocate could they recognize more how
unfair the the system is absolutely
right but the thing is is that actually
after I publish the book I have been
surprised you know Lutheran
um Refugee uh you know the one of the
volat one of the voluntary agencies
which is a national runs a lot of
different resettlement agencies reached
out to me after the book and said what
can we do better right so there is I
think a willingness and I and I do want
to work with those people for these
intermediary effects because this
impacts people's lives immediately right
and so I am really keen on supporting
you know the work of ngos who are tasked
with this and so I am reticent to to
participate in that kind of rhetoric and
the reason for that is because I think
that the real
um violence and the real crisis lies
with the government just not funding
this and so the ngos are put in an
impossible position like can we all do
our work better absolutely is there
really a way to do this well given the
resources that they have I don't think
so
thank you
my question is really related it's um
kind of I guess similar to what that the
Lutheran organization asked you um I'm
wondering um I know there's a lot of
people
um I think listening to this that are
involved in um in some way shape or form
Refugee resettlement or integration
which is a phrase I don't like because
it means integration into American
poverty but um in this room both in
person and online so I'm wondering
um what I I'm sure this would be an
elongated response but if there's
anything you could share that you shared
with the organization that reached out
to you and kind of what would be the
role um of those ngos to advocate for if
the violence is with the state to be
part of um you know upending that yeah
so there's you know so the what my
response to them was that I would be
really um uncomfortable to come up with
those answers on my own so what I
suggested was a series where we actually
discuss with key policyholders people
who interested from across the country
to come in sort of communion and have a
conversation but the way I also
approached it was to say there's like
three levels of this three levels that
you can think about in terms of how we
can reform one is like the things that
people can do with the resources that
they have at the moment so that's like
using volunteers for instance for things
like
um tutoring for things like
um you know on you know online language
things that you don't need
sustainability for for instance and not
using them for things that people
crucially need for instance
um thinking about the rhetoric that we
use right is self-sufficiency when we
talk about self-sufficiency do we talk
about it as like the goal do we say
things like refugees need to learn to be
independent or do we say you know this
is a really problematic policy we are
going to help you to the extent that we
are able within the framework of what we
can do right which is a very different
approach to the same question do we
actually recognize I mean you know
unfortunately even a well-meaning
organization has people within their
midst that are just really um
problematic right and so do we think
about do we train our staff do we have
conversations about what it means to be
um you know respectful what it means to
treat people with dignity how you
receive people how you speak to people
right is that a part of how we we sort
of identify and understand ourselves
um do we talk about do we essentialize
countries do we think Iraqis are like
this and Palestinians are like that just
something that I heard said and syrians
are like this right do we use those
kinds of language is that allowed and
accepted within our organization
um do we have opportunities for people
to learn English in the evenings do we
have opportunities for people to learn
English online
um do we give rides to people I mean
there's just like a million different
examples both from an instrumental
perspective but also from a rhetoric and
a language perspective the second the
Meso Level of this is to think about
okay what do we want to fundraise for
what are we not doing now that we can
that we want resources to be able to do
right and the third level is how do we
Advocate what are our policy points when
we're advocating with the state what do
we tell our lobbyists to say and so my
goal is to work with this organization
to be like okay if you're actually
interested let's work together and find
what these three things are what these
three buckets of things are sort of
dreams of changing the system
um dreams that are fundable and dreams
that don't need funding and can be done
right now
great
um so that so unfortunately that is all
the time that we have
um right now I invite those of you who
are in the room to stay after and just
have informal conversations with Heather
for a few minutes
um but on behalf of the program for
refugees study or for for refugees for
displacement humanitarian response and
the center for race indigeneity and
transnational migration I just want to
say thank you to all of you and
especially thank you to have that for
this
thank you